bonjour Michael j'ai quelque chose que vous
aimeriez voir
[Musique]
Deepika Nettie post Ezra Trinette loboda
sait de nouveaux Halloween
AHA Julie fan complete more for econ ho
no similarity no creo take Cosmo desk
- Fiona Davos neon perfume pardon me AHA
reserva de prendre America  David Gordon
Green illa llah value a rencontré John Carpenter
sur les femmes sur le projecteur mal nourris au total
plus de descendants de fedora Akeley redémarre
pour simuler un CV responsable de Sofia peut
rediriger le calme Deponia épisode el
macular votadoras unique une
artère unique de la tournée Jamie Lee Curtis est tombée en Corée
donc avec  la route la plus basse
ladoris et persécuté / Michael Myers
les deux arômes
l'accident de bus quel accident de bus
Mike s'est échappé Padrino hey grammaire -
subvention Mille-pattes roumain de Parme
Ozona zilmer Colvard Oh Tito otra Lori
est mon ennemi maski paratha Paco massage
[Musique]
les services soeur régime éternel  à l'
emplacement de Charton ocarina Street, ne
vous plaignez pas plus longtemps de l'échelle habla Jamie
Lee Curtis provenance ou passez le ll
futur dans la zone aphasique segaki s'ils
sont avant le football moins Agra Halloween
[Musique]
parler de films qui changent votre
vie
Halloween il y a quelques années a changé  ma
vie ça l'a fait Oh de quelle façon je veux dire de
tous les côtés que nous connaissons mais tout travail qui vous
donne vous savez que nous sommes dans une entreprise
nous voulons que les gens le regardent chaque émission que
vous voyez émission de télévision film commercial
documentaire quoi que ce soit pourquoi les faisons-nous
alors les gens vont le regarder
Halloween était un film que les gens regardaient nous
ne savions pas qu'en entrant nous étions un
groupe de jeunes cinéastes tout le monde
ressemblait à ce jeune homme ici
littéralement tout le monde était tu as trente ans
tout le monde a trente ans
petite ville deux camions  tournage très rapide
20 jours mais les gens l'ont vu et ça
vous donne alors le début d'une carrière
Halloween est devenu un succès ce n'était pas
du jour au lendemain ça a
pris quelques mois mais ça a évidemment
commencé à faire un peu d'argent et je ne
travaillais pas je ne pouvais pas  obtenir un emploi les seules
choses que j'ai faites après Halloween attendre
un épisode de Love Boat avec ma mère
jouant sa fille dans un épisode de
Love Boat et un épisode de Charlie's Angels
où j'ai joué un golfeur professionnel qui était le meilleur
ami de Cheryl Ladd et il  était John
Carpenter qui a écrit le rôle dans le brouillard
pour moi parce qu'il ne comprenait pas
qu'après Halloween je ne travaillais pas comment
expliquez-vous le succès du premier
je veux dire j'ai une explication ci-dessus avec
beaucoup d'autres en ce sens que c'était  une sorte d'
approche ik très féministe d'un zo Raja Je
sais que tu es une intellectuelle J'aime ça
chez toi et je te souhaite bonne chance avec
ton intellectualisme alors j'espère que
vous les gars de Lamond pourrez tous vous asseoir et
essayer de comprendre  Je vais vous dire ce qui
s'est passé John et Deborah ont créé un
personnage d'une vraie
fille américaine très vulnérable intellectuelle fille intelligente
douce temps total innocent et ils l'ont
jumelée, ils l'ont mise dans la ligne de
feu
du mal pur et quand cela est entré en collision
Halloween n'est arrivé personne  ne
comprendra jamais pourquoi, pas plus que quiconque ne pourra
jamais comprendre pourquoi quelque chose
réussit, personne ne sait rien,
personne ne sait rien et je sais que
personne ne sait pourquoi ce film a été un
succès et là, je suis sûr que nos
déconstructions intellectuelles de celui-ci
pourraient donner un  explication et je suis sûr que
si vous disiez qu'à John Carpenter il vous
rirait au nez, vous savez que nous ne
pouvons pas omettre la musique de la femme de chambre de John Carpenter
assise sur une argile de sable VR dans
une petite salle de montage
avec la machine  lui-même va comme
doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
ces petites piqûres vous avez tout fait donc nous
ne pouvons pas vous savez ce que je veux dire comme il
n'y a aucun moyen que nous puissions déconstruire cela et trouver
un itinéraire
il a attendu cette nuit il m'a attendu
j'ai attendu qui eh bien tu ne reviendras pas
je veux dire tu es revenu en fait à cause de
la façon dont ils racontent cette histoire
on m'a envoyé Jake Gyllenhaal comme un
de mes amis il  vient de faire un film avec un
film fantastique avec David Jake m'a envoyé un texto
et a dit que David voulait me parler je l'
ai eu au téléphone il a dit que je voulais
te dire ce que je voulais faire et j'ai
dit que je voulais juste le lire et je
l'ai lu et je l'ai rappelé et j'ai dit d'accord
faisons ça c'est
depuis le plan d'ouverture de ce nouveau
film l'image d'ouverture tu iras je
comprends tout de suite comme toi non c'est 40
ans plus tard mais nous racontons la même
histoire tout  en fait on essaie ta grand-mère
ici tu es je suis oui bien Michael
arrive Michael va s'échapper je sais
que Michael va s'échapper parce que
Laurie Strode sait qu'elle a passé
40 ans à essayer de dire aux gens que
Michael allait s'échapper  et personne
ne la croirait donc elle est très claire -
elle est la nouvelle Loomis utilise un nouveau tunnel
Chris est le nouveau Donald Pleasence
parce que Donald Pleasence savait de quoi il
était capable Laurie Strode sait
de quoi il est capable quand personne d'autre ne le fait
Je suis un  grand fan d'Halloween et le
premier et mon nouveau travail très plein d'esprit je
pense que vous serez très heureux c'est dans la
lignée de ceci est-il dit je pense que vous
serez très très heureux
merci beaucoup monsieur fini plus de paix
devera ne partez pas s'il vous plait  loin Yoko Riza
paseo de guiche Halloween donc de l'hôpital
ce chat Octobre Pacha